I'm Charlie Watson I'm 18 today actually  it's the beetle for sale  yours kid happy birthday  [Music]  what are you  so you have no idea where he came from  no idea  [Applause]  well here's the deal people can be  terrible about things they don't  understand  from now on the only person you can show  yourself around is me I'm good now I'm  good thanks  there's a war raging on our planet  if this criminal isn't found that war  may find its way sir anyone that can  help you or the family Oh  they're calling an army  I've seen firsthand these things really  are  bumblebee there is only one way to end  this war  you must protect earth and its people  take it down  this is how we stop them  you've cut me  and I'm not going anywhere  you